(soft music)
- [Narrator] US officials
believe an explosion from a bomb
or some sort of sabotage
downed the private jet
carrying Wagner Group chief,
Yevgeny Prigozhin, on Wednesday,
though they cautioned
assessments were
preliminary and incomplete.
The Wall Street Journal
had three aviation experts
with combined decades of experience
analyzing plane crashes
review the footage.
Though they said it's hard to be certain
without access to physical
evidence at the crash site,
they too saw no signs that
the plane was shot down
and said initial evidence
suggests the crash
was probably caused by an
in-flight catastrophic failure,
possibly due to a bomb or sabotage.
Here's why.
First, the plume of smoke around the plane
seems to be the remnants
of an internal explosion.
A missile strike would
create long tracks of smoke
from the missile's approach.
None are seen here.
Additionally, the jet,
an Embraer Legacy 600,
has no history of in-flight structural
or mechanical failure.
The plane also appears
mostly intact in its fall
with only one of the wings missing.
A strike from a missile
capable of reaching more than 20,000 feet
would've broken the plane apart more.
The white substance trailing
the plane is another clue
it was an internal explosion.
It's not smoke, but
rather the plane's fuel,
spraying into the air
from ruptured fuel lines.
A missile would've likely
ignited the leaking fuel,
resulting in black smoke.
The way the plane falls
also points toward an internal explosion.
It's fluttering to the
ground without control,
a possible indication
that the explosion happened
near the tail of the plane.
The somewhat contained wreckage pattern
further supports an internal explosion.
In one place, we can see
the main body of the plane,
while in another area a
mile away, we see the tail.
A missile would've scattered shrapnel
and debris more widely.
The leaking fuel appears to have ignited
when the plane's main body crashed.
Parts of the wreckage are
covered in small dents
according to the experts.
These are normal markings from impact
and probably not missile shrapnel.
The markings are caused by
bolted sections tearing apart
and broken off pieces of the plane
hitting other parts of the aircraft.
All of this supports
preliminary assessments
from US intelligence,
which say Prigozhin was killed
in an assassination plot.